since the 1960s CBS News has reported on
the impact of advancing technology on
workers with machined muscles on a
computerized brain the robots of
tomorrow will take over an astonishing
number of jobs for ma'am can I help you
find something this autonomous
multilingual robot is designed to help
customers at the home-improvement chain
Lowe's get their shopping done as
quickly as possible it's estimated in
the next 15 to 20 years 32% of jobs are
likely to change significantly due to
automation 14% could be completely
automated right now 60% of adults don't
have the skills for emerging jobs the
new book how to win in a winner-take-all
world has advice for how to succeed in
this new economy the author is New York
Times senior economic correspondent Neil
or win and Neil joins us at the table
good morning morning Tony a lot of
anxiety out there you write in the book
that the old adage of show up early work
hard and learn your trade no longer good
enough it isn't you know I think we all
learn when we're growing up the thing
you're good at do more of it if you're
good at a certain sport you keep at it
but the reality is what the modern
workplace the modern company rewards is
flexibility and the ability to adapt and
work across different specialty
functions and make teams work better
together I compared to a relay race you
know it's not just going fast when
you're in a relay race it's also about
getting the handoff right modern
companies really need that handoff to
work once they become comfortable with
discomfort
I think there's ways to do that that's
you know we think of adaptability is
something you're either born with or not
I think it's a treat that can be
cultivated anybody we're not all natural
public speakers you'll work at becoming
a better public speaker you can work at
it being adaptable by doing different
things when you're young so how did you
conclude these tips you reached out to
companies asking for their most
successful performers from Goldman Sachs
to Shake Shack first of all when you
called them and said I want to go in and
talk to you guys to figure out what your
secret sauce is what did they say to you
what was the reaction some some funny
questions I'm an economics writer
normally I write about GDP and the
unemployment numbers things like that
but I really think there's some changes
in the economy that are tied to these
changes in the corporate world so I'd go
to Microsoft or GE or Goldman Sachs and
say okay how does it work here in the
21st century what does it take to really
thrive here I think they were initially
like
well I don't know about that but but I
really found some interesting answers
and I think I think that's what's useful
for a lot of people so there are lessons
in your book for people working in big
corporations and some of these
winner-take-all companies are their
takeaways for people who are not working
in an office environment yeah look we're
not all going to work at Goldman Sachs
or Google but I think these lessons
apply across the board you know this
idea of adaptability of understanding
how you can drive technological change
not be a victim of technological change
that's true whether you're in the
executive suite or you know out on the
factory floor or in the cubicle farm
whether you shower before work exactly
one example you know Walmart's been
raising wages lately
and adding training not because they're
out of the goodness of their heart but
because they need workers were skilled
in these kind of technological changes
reshaping the retail industry you say
loyalty basically company loyalty is a
thing of the past yeah this idea that
you you know it's like a marriage isn't
really true anymore it's more like a
series of hookups yeah two or three
years move on and even if you stay with
the company for a long time I've only
had two employers that's fine to stay at
one place for a long time yeah but you
have to make sure that you're growing
and finding new opportunities within
that organization so what do you mean by
that what are some examples that people
can go home with because you talked
about a glue person what is a glue
person so a glue person is one of these
people and I met them all over the place
of these these different kinds of
organizations who really make the teams
they're on better who understand how to
work with the person with that technical
skill and this person who's in financial
in this computer programmer and make
that team come together to be better
than the sum of their parts and I think
this adaptability doing all these
different jobs exposing yourself to
different things is how you can make
yourself a glue person and those people
have a lot of success in the modern
organization I've been living my
professional life with just a regular
clock on the wall but you've given me a
new clock with a quarter million hours
on it what's the significance of that
number so if you're on the math if you
finish college at age 22 retired age 65
sleep about eight hours a night you have
about a quarter million hours to work
with that's your entire waking hours and
I think God there's all these trade-offs
we make between work and fun and family
hobbies and and I think being thoughtful
about those choices you make and and
using those quarter million hours well
and according to your own priorities for
life is the real lesson here
you know the book is called how to win
in or do winner-take-all it's not just
how to make the most money because
that's not what everybody's after it's
how to
a career that's rewarding durable
fulfilling in whatever that means for
you how much should we fear automation
we should feared a little bit I think
some of this gets over overdone I think
the key is not to fear or not for your
automation the key is to make sure you
understand how your industry is changing
how automation is going to affect it and
that you can be the person who drives
out automation drives that change rather
than one who's the victim of it who is
you know displaced and has to find
something completely new Neil Irwin
thank you very much for being with us a
lot of scary stuff but we're trying to
take it all in and understand it thanks
guys
hopefully they won't have find a way to
automate newscasters how to win in a
winner-take-all world is on sale today